[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I think we came up
with a new game show that is a surefire
hit yeah very excited about it here's
the first episode what's the game it's
time for America's unhappiest babe
America's thanks Garrity welcome back to
smeller stroke the only game show where
blindfolded contestants have to guess if
they're really smelling something or if
they're having a massive stroke let's
meet our contestants all right shalad
can Honor Roy
it says that you're a professional
butter taster and your hobbies include
wing-eating contests and holding your
breath are you ready to play smeller
stroke I don't feel well
terrific now that we've met our three
contestants it's time for round two
blindfolds down everyone all right
here's how it works
our lovely Jessica will bring out an
object which may or may not be emitting
an odor
you've got to tell us if you're really
smelling something or if you're having a
stroke
are you ready Kim me I'm ready all right
let's bring that up you've got to tell
us what do you smell right now that's
red funny
hmm I smell lasagna all right check out
that black hole Oh the casserole dish is
completely empty darkness it also means
you're having a massive stroke right now
to the consolation that was a great
stroke which leaves two contestants Josh
shush so you're ready let's do this okay
bring up the next item all right Josh
tell us what do you smell cookies
oatmeal cookies check out that light
bulb y'all I know that I look closer
just those are not a meal cookies
they're chocolate chip cookies no
oatmeal no that's a stroke are you gotta
keep surprise the high frequency of
massive strokes on this show
statistically it should not happen
which leaves Sean let's bring him
forward for the triple smell or stroke
showdown take my hug follow me and one
more step and then down from there you
got it
okay sure we're gonna bring out three
items all at once I'm already feeling
woozy that's unfortunate
let's play all right Chuck leave that it
tell us what you smell I smell the dead
skunk flowers and perfume all right they
are the pop oh yes hold on now hold on
that is a dead skunk but those are
plastic flowers and that's not perfume
at all it's just filled with water well
that's all the time we have I don't know
why there are buttons on those podiums
good night
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I know what works and that's
gonna be huge